yes it really is tragic there's been a
steady flow of people behind me laying
flowers and candles and coming together
to share their grief as in the early
hours of yesterday morning full members
of a family were stabbed to death here
on delaford road you can see directly
behind me that there is still a metal
cordon that is blocking us from access
to this road but we have recently heard
from the met police in the last hour
that have named all four of those
victims we have them here they are uh
denton burke and his partner delit hill
who was 64. they lived here together on
delaford road as well as 45 year old
tanisha ofori okufu who was donald
hill's daughter and 27 year old samantha
drummond who was tanisha's daughter so
as i say full members of that family
were tragically killed here the met
police also gave us a bit more context
as well some more detail as to what
happened in the early hours of monday
morning they said that they were alerted
to a disturbance at around 1 42 a.m when
they arrived they were very concerned
about the welfare of the people inside
the building so they forced entry where
they found the four people that had stab
wounds as well as that 28 year old man
they had to use a taser they deployed a
taser in order to detain that 28 year
old man we do not yet know his name but
we do know that he is from louis sherman
that he was taken to hospital in an
ambulance where he remains his condition
is not known well he is in a stable
condition but his injuries are not yet
known the police have also released a
statement in the last hour detective
chief inspector lindy bradley said that
this was a truly horrific
incident and she fully recognizes that
the distress for the family and
community will be overwhelming she said
that we are conducting a thorough and
detailed investigation into the facts
and are appealing for anyone who can
assist with any information to come
forward we've also heard tributes as
well from guys and said thomas nhs
foundation trust they paid tribute to
jarlett hill who is an active trade
union member they said that we are
devastated to hear about the tragic
death of donald hill who worked as a
housekeeping assistant in our department
in our pharmacy department for more than
21 years before her retirement in
2018 they said dullett was a very well
respected colleague who also helped to
improve the workplace and for others as
an active unison representative they
said that their thoughts are with
dalet's family and friends and all who
worked with her and it really has had a
huge impact on this as i said on this
community as i said lots of people have
been laying flowers directly behind me
many of them far too distressed to talk
to us on sky news but some of them have
given me some insight into this
community they said it's a very quiet
area so quiet in fact that at night you
can hear a pin drop and all of them are
very very concerned indeed to hear about
what happened to the family so we'll
bring you more details about that 28
year old man when we have them